now let's bring in fox senior strategic
analyst retired general jack keane
general um
let's just start with your thoughts on
where we stand what is it now day 11
moving into day 12 of this war your
overview
well we're 12 days into this and
certainly
you know in the russians mind they
thought this was going to take two to
three days
and the ukrainians would pretty much lay
down and not fight
and they only committed about a third of
the forces that they had deployed into
the area in the vicinity of ukraine so
we're 12 days in now
and they really haven't taken a major
city steve
ukrainian aircraft are still flying and
that absolutely stuns me
that the russians uh have not been able
to gain air superiority and take and
take the ukrainian aircraft down and
also some of their defense systems their
cyber attack which is an instrument of
national power that the russians
are very good at and we assess they're
good at it
uh has had negligible effect uh on this
campaign and their casualties
steve are way higher than anybody's
expectations here and i think they're
being very deceptive about it
they've had some success in the southern
campaign because they want to
they want to deny ukraine's access to
the black sea and the sea of azov
and but still they have a long way to go
in that campaign
and the northern campaign as we all know
which is about keeve and
kharkiv that has stalled and they have
tried to restart it a number of times
and they have not made any consequential
progress what they intend to do is go
west and east of kiev encircle the city
hammer it
and force the capitulation of the
government either they surrender or they
kill or capture them they're not even
close to that it is stunning where we
are now 12 days
is only 12 days wars last a lot longer
than that
but given what most of us believed
was a significant overmatch that the
russians had that they certainly would
have made a lot more progress than this
this is testimony certainly to the
ukrainians and their their determination
but also
uh how much they've improved since 2014
in terms of their military and the
leadership that they have and yes we are
helping them uh with weapons i think we
can do more and we've got to do more
because if this lasts longer they're
going to run out of all these tools that
are being so effective
on the russians and many of these tools
like stingers like anti-tank weapons are
coming from the united states and nato
allies and we're going to hear zielinski
screaming for them because he's going to
start to run out of them
as this campaign protracts
well let's pick up on that because i um
a couple of days ago i i recorded a
conversation with the historian neil
ferguson we're going to play a couple of
clips of that later tonight but one of
the things he said was you know echoing
the your analysis then he threw it
forward and said
if we could just help the ukrainians
hang on
for a few weeks he used to a few more
weeks
then you could see a situation where
there's just no prospect for putin of
achieving the kind of victory that he
wanted and that you get to this
stalemate
and that things could change and he
might have to accept that he's not going
to get away with it
but the key to that is giving the
ukrainians enough equipment so they can
hang on for another few weeks
do you share that
analysis
yeah yeah i mean there's no doubt about
that i mean putin has serious problems
here i mean we can dismiss the idea
right now
that putin
would be able to sustain an occupation
of ukraine of 45 million 45 million
people over time he'll never be able to
do that we've seen the evidence of that
of that here he doesn't have the forces
to occupy a country of 45 million people
not not even close and given the
casualties he's got here
that's pretty serious so that that
option is there this what we're talking
about here is very real
we can impose significant cost on him
over time
and the political situation may change
as a result of it what do we think
putin's going to do here
one
he's going to pummel a civilian
population
he'll have a lot more success bombing
the civilian population regrettably and
hammering it with artillery than he's
having
with the ukraine military
and and he wants to break the will of
that population and break the will of
its leaders by killing as many of them
as they can i think he's going to go
reach out and say
sanctions are an act of war
providing weapons to the adversary to
these fascists is also an act of war and
he's going to threaten the expansion
of the campaign to the people who are
doing that certainly cyber is the
easiest thing for him to use
in going after the sanctions and he has
a
a significant cyber capability that has
applied against us in the past we will
likely see him do that again but listen
we have got to get
all of this arms and equipment into them
on a regular sustained basis and i also
think that we could use some covert
operations to help
facilitate
delivering that equipment air dropping
some of it we have very precision point
means to do that also the the airfields
that are very remote they you know don't
even have lights on them at night
they're all over ukraine like they are
all over the united states there's a lot
of things that we can do to speed it up
and get get it into his hands and and
we're going to have to press our allies
on this as well
that our commitment we made we're not
going to
we're not going to defend them on the
ground but our commitment is we're all
in and we're not going to let this stand
and that means we got to really step up
now it has improved over what it was i
mean we delayed these arms during 2021
because we were afraid in the united
states that if we gave him the weapons
when he was mobilizing on ukraine's
border that would provoke the attack
and that that is shameful and it's a
lack of spine to come to a conclusion
like that
so this is very important i totally
agree we got it the ukrainians know full
well
that that dragging this out over time is
much to their favor to be sure
exactly and we
need to be there and i it's fantastic to
have your analysis and your specific the
specific points you made there about
exactly what we need to do we're going
to keep up the pressure general keene
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else